wir sind bei von bredow und der frage
noch mal nach mecklenburg vorpommern die
menschen reisen ja jetzt nicht nur in
den tierpark und in die baumärkte
sondern sie reisen aufgefordert
mecklenburg vorpommern auch aus ganz
deutschland in den nordosten weil sich
mecklenburg vorpommern gerne volle
hotels wünscht und wieder mehr tourismus
wünscht potenziell reist dann auch das
virus mit selbstverständlich und genauso
wird es sich weiter verbreiten
es wird ja in dieser ganzen debatte so
getan als hätten wir das virus so weit
unterdrückt dass wir jetzt alle diese
lockerungen und auch schön schrittweise
und so jetzt vollziehen können
in wahrheit krebsen wir aber immer noch
an dieser eher zahl von 1 wir sind ein
bisschen drunter
aber wir sind auch noch verdammt nah
dran und sobald es wieder darüber geht
wird das exponentielle wachstum wieder
beginnen aber diesmal der der der
virusinfektion
deswegen hätte ich es vorgezogen ich
meine haben ja alle das gleiche ziel wir
wollen schnell aus dem lot dort raus
aber wäre es nicht schlauer gewesen die
er zeit noch viel weiter runter zu
drücken den hammer noch viel viel
heftiger anzusetzen und dann hätten wir
ein viel entspannteres tänzchen haben
können nämlich wirklich entspannt
lockern können und nicht befürchten
müssen gleich mit dem nächsten was ich
geschäfte eröffnen kneipen öffnen oder
das städten öffnen gleich wieder in
dieses exponentielle geschehen rein zu
kommen und die gefahr sehen sie frau
büxt die frage die ministerpräsidenten
verweisen jetzt immer darauf deutschland
ist so heterogen wir haben
unterschiedliche betroffenen zahlen im
süden in bayern und baden württemberg
sah es ganz anders aus als im norden
oder auch im osten sorgen wir jetzt mit
diesen lockerungen nicht aber dafür dass
sich das virus tatsächlich gleichmäßiger
verteilen wird in deutschland also das
ist natürlich ganz klar die gefahr dass
die zunehmende mobilität uns jetzt
wieder in die nächsten wellen bringt
also da muss ich von mir natürlich recht
geben
ich glaube aber auch dass wir über
diesen sicherungsmechanismus ein
warnsystem haben es wird jetzt viel
davon abhängen das ist wirklich der
auftrag dass diese zusätzliche
verantwortung die jetzt auf alle zukommt
also diese neuen
einheiten die wir bekommen da ist ja ein
stock dahinter also das hat ja auch ein
bisschen was sogar erzieherisch ist dass
man sagt ihr lieben leute ihr kriegt
jetzt ein paar mehr freiheiten
aber hier ist die grenze und dann müssen
wir eventuell den hammer wieder
niedersausen lassen
das bedeutet sehr viel mehr
eigenverantwortung einmal regional für
die länder aber natürlich auch für jeden
fall eins anfangen
und ich glaube es ist ganz wichtig dass
wir da pro aktiv kommunizieren dass wir
da die bürger mitnehmen und überhaupt
die möglichkeit geben dass jemand der
reist dann sagt ich muss vielleicht auch
einfach darauf achten wie sich zahlen
entwickeln ich muss bei mir im landkreis
gucken ich weiß nicht viele haben sich
dass so ein ritual gemacht einmal am tag
die korona zahlen beim frühstückskaffee
sich anzuschauen oder auch die welt
zahlen ich mache das jeden tag aber ich
schaue mir nie die landkreis zahlen
wir müssen uns jetzt alle die landkreis
zahlen anschauen und wir sollten das da
kann man aber ganz kreative dinge
nachdenken da kann man über eine grüne
gelbe rote ampel nachdenken und wenn wir
dann in meinem landkreis gelb sind
sollte ich vielleicht selber in meinem
lebens und handlungs umfeld wie den
verteidiger salzstock und dann kommt
helge braun gleich wann kommt dann
eigentlich der bund wieder ins spiel
also wann wird aus einer regionalen
notlage dann wieder eine nationale wenn
wir zehn heinsbergs haben oder 20
heinsbergs oder nein schon bei weniger
als eins also wir haben generell gesagt
jedes gesundheitsamt dass die kontakt
nach verfolgung nicht mehr bewältigen
kann oder auch nur die sorge gehabt dass
ist nicht mehr schaffen melden das
anders robert-koch-institut und wir
haben teams aufgebaut die dann helfen
also dieses ganze thema was jetzt unter
diesem begriff obergrenze den nicht
totalen quatsch
dafür läuft starken sich ein anderer
mechanismus der darauf abzielt wenn ein
landkreis egal wie klein die zahlen sind
sagt bekommen in einer
überforderungssituation dann kommen wir
alle zum helfen dann hilft das land und
hälfte bund wären die kontakte nach
verfolgt geraden kreis habe auch
unterstützung ganz viele testungen jetzt
zu machen und wirklich das komplette
infektionsgeschehen einzudämmen
und darum geht es dass wir keine
überforderungssituation haben
jede infektionskette eindämmen und dann
geht es mit der freiheit auf der anderen
seite auch gut
dafür haben wir jetzt auch die zeit
gebraucht es aufzubauen
das war mit dem märz undenkbar aber
mittlerweile haben wir ganz viele leute
die helfen können wir haben ein tolles
meldesystem und wenn sie auf die
landkreise gucken wollen
dem robert-koch-institut sehen sie schon
in den blühenden vorhaben von grün bis
rot und herren insofern gucken wir da
jeder user ist gleich dann noch mal die
frage nach hannover derweil also die
ministerpräsidenten kriegen ja jetzt
nicht die verantwortung sondern sie
haben sie hier explizit gesucht das
heißt sie stehen dann auch in der kritik
wenn in niedersachsen die kliniken
überlastet sind
sie haben sie nicht gesucht wir haben
sie von anfang an gehabt oder so kröner
ja das macht einen großen unterschied
ich habe noch nie ihr mann erlebten
einer situation sich dann hinter der
bundeskanzlerin oder wo auch immer hätte
verstecken können
wenn bei mir etwas schlimmes passiert
wäre in niedersachsen dann hätte das
nicht funktioniert sondern hätte ich
natürlich auch zur person rede und
antwort stehen müssen da ändert sich
überhaupt nichts dran
ja ich glaube was helge braun eben
angesprochen hat das ist das
entscheidende dadurch dass wir das
niveau deutlich abgesenkt haben können
wir jetzt auch wieder sehr viel stärker
regional und damit auch letzten endes
effizienter vorgehen vielleicht mit
einem bild ausgedrückt wir haben unter
dem not der verhältnisse uns entschieden
für einen schrotschuss nämlich im grunde
genommen alles herunterzufahren und
unter der in der situation in der er
jetzt sind sind wir in der lage auch
platt schüsse zu setzen nämlich zu
schauen wo entsteht eigentlich etwas und
wo müssen wir reingehen und da kann ich
übrigens sagen diese zahlen die jetzt
diskutiert worden ist für niedersachsen
habe ich da wirklich deswegen zustimmen
können weil ich weiß wir würden im
zweifel sehr viel früher gemeinsam mit
den kommunen uns anschauen was ist da
los
sie würden früher schauen und trotzdem
noch mal die frage markus söder sagte
gestern im interview
er frage sich eigentlich auch warum man
sich nicht noch mal zwei drei wochen
mehr gegeben hat um auch seitens des
bundes in einer abgestimmten mit dem
bund und allen ländern abgestimmten
variante weiterzufahren
fragen sie sich das nicht ja ich frage
mich wenn ich das zitat höhere vor allen
dingen warum der kollege söder dann am
dienstag sein
für bayern auf den tisch gelegt hat aber
das muss ich ihn selber band so fragen
wir ihn jetzt das nächste mal ranga
yogeshwar die einen lockern und mahnen
zur vorsicht die anderen mahnen zur
vorsicht und lockern auch gibt es
eigentlich noch diese zwei bewegungen
das sieben dynamik und öffnen und das
team disziplin
ich glaube es gibt in dem kontext zwei
aspekte auf dem man genau gucken muss
das erste ist die karten die zahlen wir
müssen uns ja etwas klar machen und das
lernen wir so langsam im laufe dieser
pandemie dass diese offiziellen zahlen
die wir haben nur einen teil der
wirklichkeit widerspiegeln nämlich nur
die menschen die getestet worden
und wir wissen inzwischen dass die
anderen die manchmal mit geringen
symptomen aber trotzdem infektiös dass
die nicht in dieser statistik drin sind
das heißt wir haben sozusagen manche
sind auch völlig also automatisch ihren
geiseln genommen und ihn schon durch
dann aber sind unter umständen infektiös
das heißt diese zahlen sind zum ersten
mal wackelig der fehler in der
konstruktion meines erachtens liegt in
zwei dingen das erste ist ja man muss
sicherlich sehr lokal gucken wo sie auch
vorher gibt also insofern wenn es
irgendwann ganz große unterschiede gibt
kann man sagen in dem einen bundesland
oder in der region kann man lockerer
umgehen als in einer anderen aber der
fehler der konstruktion liegt meines
erachtens in seiner grundstruktur die
ich würde sie bezeichnen mit niemand ist
bereit den ast abzusägen auf dem er
sitzt denken wir das noch mal sehr
komplett durch also wir haben jetzt eine
geschundene region die einen langen
lockdown hatte und jetzt machen die auf
was passiert in diesem gesundheitsamt
was wird passieren in der motivation zu
testen wenn plötzlich ganz viele
betriebe sagen mein gott wenn du jetzt
noch mehr test ist findest du vielleicht
50 und dann müssen wir zu machen wie
viel druck wird auf diesen beamten
lasten die eines tages kommen und sagen
er die zahlen sind hoch wie wird man
dann versuchen die möglicherweise sogar
so zu glätten oder umzudeuten also das
merkt man jetzt schon heute ja
dass diese zahl 50 nicht in beton
gemeißelt ist sondern da schon ein reiz
nicht irgendwo sagt ja das kann man an
dass man sich glaube das ist doch na ja
also wenigsten von ihnen ignoriert weil
sie sieben oder reinfall
und ich glaube das ist gefährlich weil
diese signalwirkung führt eigentlich
eher in einer verdrängung wir haben das
in anderen bereichen gesehen ich
erinnere nur mal an die luftmessungen in
städten ja wo ab einem gewissen
schwellenwert sogar brüssel informiert
werden musste und man sagen musste okay
dann kein autoverkehr in der stadt und
wenn man sich das wirklich mal in
deutschland anschaut merkt man mit
welcher kreativität hier zahlen ja
irgendwie gepolstert wurden damit man
unter dieser schwelle bleibt und ich
habe einfach die sorge dass wir die
wichtigkeit dieser zahl vor dem druck
der anderen interessen die durchaus
verständlich sind möglicherweise
korrumpieren also da wär mir lieber eine
echte unabhängigkeit des testens und
einen anderen mechanismus und anderen
mechanismus jetzt hat er brown so heftig
widersprochen ich merke gerade dass ich
sie nach gar nicht gefragt habe also
auch an sie die frage wenn die landrätin
sagt ich mache trotzdem auf und wir
werden trotzdem lockern so wie wir uns
das in thüringen überlegt haben was will
der bund tun was soll wer da tun also
ganz klar ist dass zum beispiel
thüringen hat heute diese regelung mit
dem notfallmechanismus ecall in seine
regeln übernommen das heißt es gilt dort
jetzt und das werden sie auch umsetzen
und die aufgabe es gibt keinen
automatismus für einen breiten breite
kontakt beschränkung sondern es gibt
jetzt die notwendigkeit die müssen oder
offenlegen wie ist dieser ausbruch
geartet und wie wollen sie ihn eindämmen
und dann da es sich hier um einen
ausbruch handelt der in der tat mir das
auch eben schon angesprochen wurde in
pflegeeinrichtungen insbesondere ist
sehr abgegrenzt kann ich mir gut
vorstellen dass die eine beschränkung
konzept hinbekommen was nicht mit ganz
breiten allgemeinen beschränkungen aus
kommt das weiß ich aber nicht
wir sind jetzt erst mal vorlegen damit
es von experten bewährt die sorge der
yogeshwar gerade geäußert hat daher
glaube ich kann man auf deutschland ein
bisschen mehr vertrauen nicht jeder
landrat
hat doch nur ein an sind er möchte dass
sein landkreis möglichst frei von
infektion ist und das dümmste was man
machen könnte wäre bei 40 infektionen
aufhören zu testen weil das diesmal
anders als bei manchen anderen krisen
kommt man da nicht unbemerkt irgendwie
durch sondern einfach irgendwann mit 100
oder 200 infektionen wieder auf mit
überforderten krankenhäusern und deshalb
glaube ich ist es auch nicht so das ist
hier kein blame game es geht nicht darum
irgendjemandem zu sagen deine zahlen das
sind zu hoch sondern um einfach deutlich
zu machen wenn wir irgendwo in
deutschland ein problem lösen wir das
solidarisch wir kommen zum testen wir
kommen zur kontakt nachverfolgung wir
arbeiten alle daran dass es sowas wie
heinsberg oder hitzschke oder anderen
orten die wir vorher schon hatten nicht
wieder ein deutschlandweites problem
wird und am ende kommt auch dieser
landkreis dadurch schneller durch die
krise weil wir alle zusammenhang aber
wollte die kannst es nicht nur
sprachlich 35 infizierte auf 100000
einwohner haben sie da auch schon
lockern müssen die mehr als mein
vorschlag auch das nachher braun der tat
ein bisschen niedriger da reingehen die
55 ist schon relativ hoch also wenn wir
das auf eine stadt wie hamburg oder
berlin mal hochrechnet das sind dass das
ist das muss jedem klar sein das ist
nicht so dass wir jetzt dann urplötzlich
uns anfangen irgendwo einzumischen was
man eigentlich alle in ruhe lassen
sollte sondern da muss die feuerwehr
kommen weil dann brennt der dachstuhl
lichterloh und also hätten sie lieber
dafür plädiert 35 und sagen heute hier
aber dass sie gerne vertrauen wollen und
dass sie hoffen dass verlangt räte auch
schon bei dreisel residenten sogar schon
rückmeldung bekommen dass die debatte
die wir da angestoßen haben ihnen jetzt
auch noch mal deutlich gemacht hat dass
man da so genau hin bekommen haben und
die ziehen jetzt sogar landesspezifisch
unterhalb der 50er grenze noch mal so
einen eigenen mechanismus unten drunter
und zu sagen bevor wir da überhaupt
hinkommen wollen wir lieber bei 30 oder
25 schon mal eigene maßnahmen ergreifen
also das was hier gerade passiert ist
ziemlich gut ja weil das ziel jetzt
wirklich ist bei den niedrigen zahlen
sehr liebevoll jeden ausbruch einzeln
mit viel energie zu betrachten damit wir
nicht diese zweite welle
haben festgestellt in den letzten zwei
wochen alle miteinander dass der druck
ordentlich wuchs und das was wir jetzt
diskutieren ist ausdruck dieses druckes
und er wuchs in der wirtschaft und er
wuchs in der politik und auch in der
gesellschaft der konsens bröckelte in
einem manifest forderten sechs
persönlichkeiten des öffentlichen lebens
den strategiewechsel denn zugleich ist
der lockdown im begriff unser soziales
kulturelles und wirtschaftliches leben
zu ruinieren
wir müssen gesundheit wirtschaft und
rechtsstaat gleichermaßen schützen so
wie wir es derzeit an gehen laufen wir
gefahr alle drei ziele zu verfehlen und
die wirtschaft ächzt unter dem
wochenlang lockdown es müssen sich
natürlich alle auch darüber im klaren
sein dass wir jede woche einen
zweistelligen milliardenbetrag
verbrennen
und es geht nicht ums verbrennen allein
sondern für viele unternehmen für viele
freiberufler wird es ums überleben geben
das ist jetzt eine frage an frau von
renault sind die gesellschaftlichen
folgen die wirtschaftlichen sozialen
folgen von bredow zu lange nicht gesehen
worden in der zeit des lotter doch
selbstverständlich das war ja von anfang
an eingepreist dass das kann ja jeder
sehen das sieht jeder in seinem privaten
umfeld wie sehr leute auch leiden unter
dem blog dass alleinerziehende die ihre
kinder nicht in die kita geben können
friseure die ihren beruf nicht ausüben
können
da fällt einem jahrtausend beispiele ein
und natürlich verlängert sich mit der
dauer des lockouts auch das leiden
dieser menschen nur die frage ist ja
tatsächlich wie verkürzen wir den locker
und da würde ich immer sagen muss man
auf die wissenschaft hören und die
wissenschaft hat sehr deutlich und sehr
klar vor drei wochen gesagt also
verschiedene szenarien ausgerechnet und
das sind ja nicht irgendwelche szenarien
die sich ergeben wenn man mal die würfel
auf den tisch fallen lässt sondern das
war richtig gute durchgerechneten
szenarien von forschern der helmholtz
gesellschaft und die haben ziemlich klar
ergeben dass wir wenn wir richtig
strengen den lockdown noch durchhalten
man wusste nicht genau wie lange aber so
zwei drei wochen werden schon drin
gewesen dann hätte es dann hätten wir
die zahl so weit runter gekriegt dass
wir was ich eben schon mal gesagt habe
ein bisschen entspannter in den in die
lockerungen gehen können jetzt sehen wir
doch übrigens auch an der zahl der
obergrenze die sie ja so ein bisschen
feiern wie es mir scheinen will dass die
wissenschaft da überhaupt keine rolle
gespielt hat sondern dass das ein deal
ist und da frage ich mich schon wie
kommt man auf so eine zahl von 50
ausgerechnet und eben nicht 35
wieso handy kann man einfach die kap das
ist ja fast frivol eine solche zeit zu
erfinden praktisch nein sie ist nicht
erfunden sondern die 35 sind sehr leicht
ableitbar wir hatten damals gesagt wir
brauchen einen kontakt nach verfolgung
steam pro 20.000 einwohner das war die
empfehlung des robert koch-instituts dh
5 pro hunderttausend mal sieben tage
sind 35 das ist quasi unsere kapazität
für die kontakt nachverfolgung und
deshalb wäre 35 das wo wir sagen das
schafft ein landkreis noch alleine
das haben wir jedenfalls so verabredet
und wenn es mehr wird braucht er dann
hilfe von bund und land und wenn er dann
sagt der landkreis er braucht hilfe er
bekommt sie und wenn er trotz der hilfe
dann noch die 50 überschreitet deshalb
die 15 mehr
dann müssen wir wirklich mit allem was
wir haben uns dort engagieren noch ein
widerwort ja das trägt den ja überhaupt
nicht rechnung dass das
infektionsgeschehen möglicherweise ganz
anders verläuft wenn wir jetzt im sommer
zum beispiel eine gewisse beruhigung
haben gewissen saisonalen effekt dann
wird sich dieses virus unter der decke
still und heimlich weiter verbreiten im
ganzen land und wenn dann die zweite
welle kommt papst das komplett hoch ist
wir wollen im sommer 150.000 menschen
repräsentativ durch ganz deutschland mit
dem neuen jetzt sehr guten
antikörpertest mal testen und dann
werden wir diese dunkelziffer ziemlich
gut aufklären können also dann haben wir
ein stärkeres gefühl ob wir wirklich in
der bevölkerung so eine
hohe immunitätsrecht abend oder
vielleicht doch was hat er ist
vielleicht ein etwas hat derweil ist
auch gleich dran
was hat sich an dieser abwägung zwischen
freiheit und gesundheit geändert ist das
virus jetzt weniger gefährlich weil wir
diese guten zahlen haben oder ist der
gesellschaftliche schaden tatsächlich
hochgerechnet dann so exponentiell
das ist die berühmte kurve derweil
erwähnte was glauben sie was hat sich an
der abwägung verändert oder hat sich
eigentlich nichts verändert und der
druck ist nur gestiegen also wir haben
tatsächlich vor sechs wochen in unserer
stellungnahme vom deutschen ethikrat
schon genau auf diese abwägung
hingewiesen also auf diese schäden die
man auch glaube ich nicht einfach so
beiseite schieben kann und sagen kann
zwei drei wochen länger das geht schon
dann gehen wir ein bisschen entspannter
wenn ich sie da zitieren der frau von
bredow in die lockerungen da geht es bei
jeder woche um dramatische folgen und da
geht es auch nicht nur um die
wirtschaftlichen folgen da geht es eben
um die familien die wirklich zum teil in
der verzweiflung sind also ich hab heute
auf dem weg in diese sendung so viele
nachrichten von freunden gekriegt die
gesagt haben sagt bitte wie fürchterlich
dass für uns eltern ist wir haben so
viele effekte auch gesundheitliche
effekte psychische erkrankung
ausgefallene behandlung und so weiter
und so fort das wissen wir alle dass man
nicht sagen kann zwei drei wochen das
ist nichts also der konflikt besteht
weiter und wird immer drängender der
zweite punkt ist dass wir da ja auch
grundrechte einschränken an ganz vielen
stellen und auch da müssen wir das haben
wir schon damals relativ klar formuliert
obwohl er schon eine weile her ist und
da die zahl noch viel viel viel
schlechter aussahen
wir müssen immer wieder neu begründen
warum wir diese drastischen
einschränkungen behalten und wenn wir
mechanismen finden wir haben diese art
von grenze nicht auf skizziert aber wir
haben schon in dieser stellungnahme
darauf hingewiesen wenn wir mechanismen
finden verantwortlich zu öffnen haben
wir eine pflicht da pläne für zu
entwickeln nicht alles aufzureißen aber
stufenweise und und wohlüberlegte
vorsichtige pläne zu machen und das ist
eine ganz ungewöhnliche situation für
eine ethikerin dass die da nichts zu
meckern hat was jetzt passiert ist aber
sondern sagen muss das entspricht
latif gut einem weg von dem wir damals
gesagt hätten das ist ein mittelweg es
ist weder normalität davon kann niemand
reden also im biergarten mit anderthalb
metern abstand hat sich noch nie
umsetzen grenze aber es ist eben auch
nicht die illusion zu glauben wir
müssten die zahl jetzt auf fünf brücken
oder wir würden das virus aushungern
können wir werden auch weiter austausch
mit anderen ländern irgendwann haben
wollen das ist jetzt in der welt und ich
glaube wir müssen uns klarmachen wir
werden damit so lange leben müssen bis
wir eine effektive behandlung und noch
besser eine wirksame impfung haben und
das ist noch eine ganz schön lange zeit